working together anya and bill stained a
large porch deck in eight hours
last year anja stained the deck by
herself the year before bill painted it
by himself but it but took twice as long
as anya did how long did anya and bill
take when each was painting the deck
alone so let's define some variables
here let's define a
let's
define a as number
of
hours of hours
for
anya
to paint a deck to paint
a deck and so we could say that anya
anya paints or has eight a hours
eight hours per one deck
or we can invert this
and say
that she can do one over a dex
one over a dex per hour
now let's do another variable for bill
just like that
let's define b as the number
of hours
for
bill
to paint a deck
paint
uh
deck
and so for bill
he can paint it takes him b hours
per deck for one deck we could put it
over one there if we want we don't have
to
and this is the same thing as saying
that it take he can do
one deck
per every b hours
v hours or another way to think of it is
he can do one over b
deck per hour
now when they work together anya and
bill stained a large porch deck in eight
hours
so let's write this down anya plus bill
anya plus bill
do it orange
anya
and bill
this information right here anya and
bill stained a large porch
deck in eight hours so we could say
eight
hours
per deck
or eight or eight hours per one deck
which is the same thing as saying
one
deck
one deck
per
eight hours
and this is going to be the combination
of each of their rates so this one deck
of eight for eight hours this is going
to be equal to anya's rate
1 over a
decks per hour
plus
bill's rate plus
we do that same color
plus 1 over b decks per hour
decks per hour
so we have one equation set up let me
scroll down a little bit and i won't
write the units anymore we have 1 8
is equal to
1 over a
1 over a plus 1 over b
plus 1 over b now we have two unknowns
so we need another equation if we're
going to solve these
let's see it tells us
it tells us right here the year before
bill painted it by himself but took
twice as long as anya did so the number
of hours it takes bill to paint the deck
is twice as long as the number of hours
it takes on you to pay the deck so b is
equal to
2a the number of hours bills takes is
twice as the number of hours anya takes
per deck so b is equal to 2a so we can
rewrite this equation
as
i'll stick to the colors for now we
could say 1 8.
is equal to one over anya
instead of writing one over bill
we would write so plus one over bill is
two times on the number of hours bill
takes is two times the number of hours
anja takes so 2 times anja and now we
have one equation in one unknown and we
can solve for a the easiest way to solve
for a right here is if we just multiply
both sides of the equation by 2a so
let's multiply both sides of this by 2a
multiply the left side by 2a actually
let's multiply both sides by 8a so we
get rid of this 1 8 as well
a and then multiply the right hand side
by 8 a as well the left-hand side 8a
divided by 8 divided by 8 is just a
a is equal to 1 over a times 8 a is just
going to be 8 1 over 2a times 8a 8a
divided by 2a is 4 right 8a over 2a is
4. so a the number of on the number of
hours it takes on you to paint a deck
and i made it lower case
which i shouldn't have well these should
all be capital a's these should all be
capital a's so you have eight this is a
is equal to eight a over eight over a is
eight eight a over two a is four
so the number of hours it takes on you
to paint a deck or a
is 12 hours now what are they asking
over here
they're asking
how long did anya and bill take when
each was painting alone so we figured
out anya it takes her eight hours and
then we know that it takes bill twice as
long as anya bill is two times a so bill
is going to be 2 times 12 so bill
is equal to 2 times anya which is equal
to 2 times 12 hours which is equal to
24 hours so when they're alone it would
take anya 12 hours it would take bill 24
hours when they do it combined it takes
eight hours which makes sense because if
bill took 12 hours by himself combined
they would take six hours they would
take half as long but bill isn't that
efficient he's not as as efficient
design so it takes them a little bit
longer it takes them eight hours but it
makes sense that combined they're going
to take less time than individually